since it turns out that you loved father
v
sun battles then why not have a
follow-up to that i know it wasn't too
long ago but i feel that you'll enjoy
some more moments that employ that
special father and son dynamic so here
we go
but before we start off the list i want
to give a shout out to the sponsors of
this video
tapitude tabbytune for those of you who
aren't familiar with it is a webcomic
website that provides you with the
latest updates on some smash hit korean
series
like solo leveling and cherry blossoms
after winter with tapitune you can
follow these series without missing a
beat
and they're available in not only
english but also french and german
if those big hits aren't what you're
looking for you can take your time
scouring through the site's huge library
of over
300 titles that come in all genres i
myself have been reading a lot of solo
leveling because i love action fantasy
series and wanted to see what the hype
was all about
and i'm definitely not disappointed and
i think that it's quickly become one of
my favorite webtoons thanks in large
part to tappy tunes neat looking online
reader with many clamoring for it to get
an anime adaptation now's the best time
for you to start reading up on him if
you're up for some webtoon binge and
want to get into the hype train for some
of the latest trendy comics
check this website out or click on the
link in the description box it's my
personal number one webtoon site and i'm
sure that you're gonna like it too with
that out of the way
let's start now shall we we go back to
castlevania once more as we take a look
at alucard's battle against dracula
[Music]
in a series full of thrilling fights we
get yet another winner in this father
versus sun battle it's a battle between
two titans and it didn't disappoint one
bit the fight itself was good but the
fallout and the revelations that came
out of it are what made this fight
really cool for me
i'm sure i'm not the only one who felt a
whole lot of feels at the heartbreaking
scene at the end of the battle it's such
a strong moment
packaged within an insane fight to keep
us on the edge of our seats take note
though at this point dracula is just a
shell of himself he hasn't fed in a
whole year he just came from another
fight
and he himself wanted to die and yet it
still took going through a lot of hoops
to finally give him his much desired
death imagine prime dracula here
no one would even stand a chance
next is yomi versus shura
last time we had a fight from yu yu haku
show's three kings arc guess what
it's not the only father versus sun
fight in that very same arc that
specific arc also gave us another father
versus sun battle which features shura
versus yomi when the two got paired
together in the tournament it would seem
that yomi would have a cake walk to the
next round
after all shura's whole origin story is
about him being created so that yomi
would have an easier time winning the
tournament but what happens
when the dog bites back a surprisingly
exciting fight that's what despite his
entire reason for existing
shura refuses to back down and even puts
up a better fight than i expected of
course though he would fall to his
father in the end but that plucky
showing deserves some cutest of you to
ask me
next in line is meliodas versus demon
king
it took a long time coming for this
fight ever since i started getting into
seven deadly sins i always had the
thought that this fight in particular
would look awesome some people consider
this one of the main highlights of
season four
and i can see why everyone was so hyped
that the fight was finally happening and
in it we got a good old underdog versus
humongous boss fight that we haven't
seen too much as far as meliodus is
concerned i also don't mind the
friendship power victory because it's
pretty much a shown and staple i've
grown to like given that we're talking
about modern seven deadly sins here it's
not much of a surprise to have some
lapses in animation and all the fight
finds its way to the list through the
story and narrative wait it's one of
meliotis's most important fights in the
series as a whole and there's no one
better to give it to him than his own
father
in a change of pace the next moment
isn't a fight instead it's the cooking
showdown between soma and joyciro
now we're talking who said that we can
only include physical fights where
father and son try to beat each other
down soma versus georgiiro for the 490th
time marks an important part of the
totsuki autumn election arc
it's the long-awaited return of soma's
father after his initial appearance and
he's just the perfect person to come out
and test his son's progress it's an
intense cooking jewel that pits somas
apple risotto against his father's
special ramen soma couldn't have picked
a deceptively complex dish to use as his
trump card against his father but he
executes his plans to perfection
crafting a dish meant to revitalize the
judges in the end
georgeiro wins and soma has yet to
surpass his father looks like it's not
yet time for our upstart to overcome his
dad but it's just the start of the
journey of improvement
next is yet another moment lacking in
physicality lelouch
versus charles from code gears
lts really had a great build up for the
climax each episode
ramped the stakes up and everyone was
caught under the spell of the show as it
moved towards the end episodes 20 and 21
hit me particularly hard and is largely
due to the tension in the final
confrontation between lelouch and
charles
it's truly the tension and the catharsis
that carried this moment because
admittedly i don't consider it much of a
duel yeah you could argue that charles
had his chance to win and all but once
the plans for ragnarok gets revealed
it's all over for our tyrant emperor
lelouch empathically says goodbye to the
future charles and visions by turning
the gods against him
seeing charles and marianne get
disintegrated did give me mixed emotions
to be honest still i think that what
makes this moment is amazing isn't the
spectacle itself but how well it
captured the two side's convictions it
also put lelouch's character development
near its completion right in time for
the series grand finale
anyone got a sense of deja vu because i
featured this fight on a previous list
not too long ago for such an underwatch
show the dragon quest anime is awesome
especially if you're a shonen junkie who
just loves to reminisce about the good
old days as i said before
this fight just reeks of dragon ball
super vibes what i failed to mention
before though is that this is a father
versus sun fight and it's one that's
simply on point the action is great the
animation is awesome and the pacing is
just perfect
all you have to do is watch the fight to
see the dragon ball vibes that i'm
talking about however this fight is no
slouch even when put aside those dragon
ball fights that i've been referencing
throughout this entry this fight just
exceeded all of my expectations for the
anime and i'm sure glad that i picked
the show up
finally we have trunks versus vegeta
for all the talk i've been doing about
dragon ball it's about time we actually
feature a fight from the show now isn't
it luckily in a franchise with history
as rich as dragon ball we have a whole
gallery of fights to choose from for me
the one i'll give a nod to turns out to
be vegeta versus future trunks from
dragon ball super what's interesting
about this fight is that it's not
exactly a grudge match or a fight to the
death although i won't blame you if you
were to think that it was given the
level of intensity the two went at it
trunks wants a sparring session and all
he needs to win is to land a hit on his
father a hit that seems to be impossible
to land as his father starts lecturing
him however that leads to a surprise
headbutt and a win for trunks out of
technicality it's a nice refresher a pit
stop that serves as trunks's mini
training arc in his bid to defeat goku
black father and son sure don't hold
back
that more or less wraps up this video on
father versus sun moments in anime do
you like the lineup here more than the
previous one feel free to make me hear
your thoughts before you leave if you
enjoyed the video you might want to
consider channel memberships you can get
access to extra videos that way
and you'll do a lot in helping me make
these videos even better a patreon link
is also down there if that's the route
you want to go
i'll be happy to have you on board
either way don't forget to check out the
sponsors of this video tapitune if
you're up for some webtoon binging or
want to get into the hype train for some
of the latest trendy comics
check this website out or click on the
link in the description box i really
hope that you like the video and i hope
to see you again next time